hello to all the psychos out there and
the casual fans too
welcome to the rotten tomatoes binge
guide
i'm dule hill from the new movie psych 2
lassie
come home which is now streaming on
peacock so
if you love it and our other movie and
our entire series
and why wouldn't you here is a list of
five titles that are definitely worth
your bench time
check it out thanks toulet and i'll take
it from there as we kick things off with
our certified fresh pick veronica mars
this fan favorite show about a high
school student by day and a fearless
private investigator by night helped
cement kristen bell as a
bonafide star it was canceled after
three seasons back in 2007 but they
ultimately put out a partially
kickstarter funded certified fresh movie
in 2014 and returned with a fourth
season
in 2019 and critics praised the show for
its sharp writing
excellent acting and thoughtful subject
matter binging all four seasons and the
movie will take you about 54 and a half
hours and be sure to keep track of how
many times veronica asks her dad to buy
her a pony
next is our throwback pick this week
monk which debuted back in 2002.
this one follows an ex-detective who
battles ocd while working as a
consultant to help police solve crimes
and like psych it ran for eight seasons
on usa
monk is anchored by star tony shalhoub
who picked up three emmys during the
show's run
as critics say he brings both beguiling
eccentricity
and rich humanity to the character it'll
take you about
92 hours to binge the whole series but
the hand washing techniques you'll pick
up will definitely come in handy given
our current situation
and moving on to our rotten pick that we
love it's going to the 2009 film
mystery team starring a young donald
glover this is about a group of former
child detectives who step into the world
of
grown-up crime it was a feature film
debut for future stars like aubry plaza
and ellie kemper and one critic review
at the time from variety called it
genuinely funny but amateurishly
constructed
with just a 1 hour and 37 minute run
time you can quickly scratch that
detective buddy comedy itch
and stepping in is our brand new pick
this week it's going to the abc series
stumptown
with the certified fresh first season
finishing up in march and
a second on the way this one stars kobe
smulders as a sharp-witted marine
veteran who becomes a private
investigator in portland
where she also takes care of her brother
with down syndrome
helping give it an offbeat feel or
actors like michael ealy and jake
johnson
and critics say this is a show that
moves at a brisk pace and packs a
serious punch you can binge the first
season in just over 13 hours and i'll
totally understand if you get thirsty
for coffee while watching
and finally our editor's pick this week
goes to another one word title
and that's chuck this nbc show about a
computer geek who unwittingly downloads
government secrets into his brain ran
for
five fresh seasons and was a big hit
with fans thanks to a great mix of
action
and comedy chuck helped launch the
career of shazam himself
zachary levi and critics call it a smart
mix of workplace comedy and spy thriller
conventions that is
funny sharply paced and deftly written
with a total bench time of about 65
hours you can also try picturing the
other feature superhero who auditioned
for the role of chuck
chris pratt alright friends hopefully
this will get you psyched for your next
few bench sessions be sure to let us
know what you are currently streaming in
the comments and if you don't want to
miss out on any future recommendations
based on the shows and movies that you
love
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell as always thank you
guys for watching the rotten tomatoes
binge guide and we hope to see your face
in the next video bye
you